okay I just have one one thing at the
top for all of you first I want to uh to
wish a happy Hanukkah to all who
celebrate this evening the president and
the first lady will host a Hanukkah
reception at the White House following a
blessing and the menorah lighting the
president will address the rise of
anti-Semitism in the U.S and around the
world and reiterate that we must
continue to forcefully reject all form
of hate anti-Semitism and violence in
our country the president and the first
lady will also Mark a new tradition
adding the first ever White House
Menorah to the White House Collection
marking the first Jewish artifact to be
added to the White House archives which
was made by the White House carpentry
shop last week the president launched a
new effort to develop a national
strategy to counter the scourge of
anti-Semitism earlier this year he
convened a first of its kind Summit to
combat hate field violence the president
has secured the largest increase in
federal funding ever for the physical
security and non-pro non-profits
including synagogue and Jewish community
centers with that Darlene you want to
kick us off yes ma'am
um is there any comment that you'd like
to offer on the fact that the January 6
committee is
has held its final public hearing it's
wrapping up its work is preparing to
release the report on Wednesday
and you've heard me say this many times
and the president as well we've been
very clear from the beginning that what
we saw on January 6 was the worst attack
on our democracy since the Civil War and
the president has been very clear our
democracy continues and remains under
threat and we all have a have a part to
protect it the committee has been doing
important bipartisan work to get to the
truth of what happened on that very day
so we can we can make so we can make
sure that that doesn't happen again so
I'll leave it there what about the um
the committee's referrals of four
members of Congress to the house Ethics
Committee for ignoring subpoenas to
participate in the investigations so you
know what darling that's a very good
question and what I would say to you is
that you would have to ask those those
very Republicans uh their own to to
speak for their own actions here and
have them explain themselves look I'm
not going to get into the weeds of the
investigation from here and the process
but again you should have them explain
themselves on this very issue
question
republican-led states have asked the
Supreme Court to intervene and not allow
title 42 to expire on Wednesday as a
different court has said is there any
reaction to that and is the
administration in some way uh hoping
that the court will intervene and extend
title 42
to help you all out of this situation
that is brewing at the border so look
I'm not going to get into any legal
determinations or speculations or you
know jump get ahead of the process here
doj is clearly leading this
investigation what I can tell you is
what the Homeland homeland security has
been doing as you all know uh secretary
mayorkis was that was at the border just
last week he talked about how they are
surging resources to the border and we
have additional robust planning underway
but we need Congress to give us the
funds we've requested to do this in a
safe orderly and human main way and
here's the thing if Republican Congress
are serious about protecting the Border
if they are serious about securing the
borders they are serious about the
challenges that we're currently seeing
that they should be able to uh be able
to get involved here and make sure that
the men and women of the Department of
Homeland Security have the resources
they need they they are going to need to
do their jobs I know you guys are seeing
uh some charts behind me but again just
listing out this is what is needed this
is what we're asking that 3.5 billion
dollars of funding requests that we're
asking of Congress and also this is uh
what we have been doing to Surge
resources at the border to to deal with
uh to address the when the when title 42
has to be lifted on Wednesday
to follow on that uh the mayor of El
Paso said over the weekend that the
influx of migrants on Wednesday will be
incredible he said it will be huge and
that they're not prepared to deal with
it with the current resources that they
have so you know you have the chart up
here but you know can you walk us
through uh what the plan is to help that
City absolutely so let me just give you
what the DHS is doing and this includes
uh making sure that we give assistance
to those very cities like El pasos for
example uh DHS has deployed additional
agents and processing capabilities to El
Paso and 23 000 agents are working to
secure the southern border let's not
forget those 23 000 agents is a that is
a historic number and that's because of
the work that this president has done
and so that's the most ever that we've
ever seen doing this work and it's in
addition to nearly 1 000 border patrol
processing coordinators DHS has also put
in place Technologies like linear ground
detection systems and automated
surveillance towers and is increasing
security at ports of Entry they're also
adding 10 soft-sided CBP holding
facilities but again we need Congress to
provide us the additional resources
we've requested to do this in a safe
orderly and humane way if they are
serious republicans in Congress are
serious about securing the Border then
they should assist in making sure the
men and women at the DHS have what they
need to get this done you mentioned
surging resources I had asked you in
September specifically about El Paso and
you had said at the time that DHS the
administration was surging resources to
the region working quickly to working to
quickly decompress the area has that
surge of resources been maintained for
the last several months and is this is
that sustainable you know now if you're
talking about another surge of resources
is that on top of what had already been
done in September and how long can you
keep doing that surge like that so A
couple of things things I mean that's
one of the reasons we're asking for
additional funding that 3.5 billion
dollars and look that scale up air and
ground
transportation capabilities to move
migrants from processing to less crowded
border patrol sectors and quickly remove
them if they don't have a legal basis to
remain as set up additional CBP funding
uh holding facilities pardon me and
speed up the processing time so
individuals can have their Asylum claims
uh heard faster hire more than 300
additional agents to join our force of
23 000 agents working to secure the
border secure additional Technologies
and equipment like automated processing
processing systems law enforcement
radios upgraded surveillance and
inspection Technologies and much more
increased support for borders cities and
towns like El Paso look this is why
we're asking Congress for this
additional funding again if republicans
in Congress are serious if they want to
help the men and women at the DHS they
serve currently will assist and get this
funding to us to get this get this
additional support and resources to uh
to the men and women at the DHS is the
by demonstration looking at sending
migrants to Mexico via the expedited
removal process if title 42nd so look I
know there have been been a lot of
rumors a lot of speculations I just I'm
not going to go off of everything I
wouldn't go off of everything that
you're hearing quite yet but we will
have some more to share tomorrow and and
there will be a call too on this very on
these very varying varying issues oh
thank you and there's estimates of 50
000 buyers in Mexico waiting to cross if
title 42 ends is that accurate and would
that overwhelm the border patrol so look
I I don't don't have a
um a number for you at this time what I
can say is that we know smoggers will
try to spread misinformation to take
advantage of these vulnerable migrants
but I want to be very clear here the
fact fact is that the removal of title
42 does not mean the border is open
anyone who suggests otherwise is simply
doing the work of these Smugglers who
again are spreading misinformation and
which are which is very dangerous when
title 42 goes away as we are uh as we
have to do because of a court order
which is on Wednesday as all of you know
we will go back to title eight which
allows a process to make sure that
people can make their Asylum claims
heard of those who do not have a legal
basis to remain will be quickly removed
and so we will continue to fully enforce
our immigration laws in a fair orderly
and Humane manner but again we need
Congress to deliver on the funding that
we're requesting from them okay
um the president's been very adequivocal
against criticism for from truth toward
his predecessor related to January 6 and
in the wake of January 6th but does he
agree with the the statement from
congresswoman chain today that uh the
former president is unfit to hold any
office to this country so look as it
relates to January as it relates to uh
the January 6 committee uh we've been
pretty clear on here right from here
we're going to be very very careful to
not to politicize this process at all
the committee's work has been
substantive and based on facts some of
the actions that they are taking involve
potential criminal investigation as you
as you know so I just want to be very
careful and refer you to the Department
of Justice on those because this
Administration and the doj conduct
criminal investigation independently
free of any sort of any kind of uh
political interference or any
interference at all but what I can say
and what you've heard from this
President these past two years is he's
going to consistently speak out about
this about what happened on that day
will continue to speak out about
defending our democracy against ongoing
threats and he's not going to shy away
from that but we're just not going to
comment any further as you know this
could be there there is a potential
correct criminal investigation okay and
in the Memoir on immigration a couple
months ago was in this room who's
talking about the Intensive diplomatic
effort that's underway particularly with
three countries uh that it started to
kind of Drive the makeup of the
composition of some of the migrants
where we have little or no diplomatic
relations with those countries which
complicate things on the Asylum side uh
if they're getting breakthroughs or any
agreements on those particular
diplomatic efforts particularly in the
lead up to win sects so look as you know
uh the president of ecuadores was here
that wasn't the main topic clearly uh
one of the topics was
[Music]
migration and you know I can go more
into that if you will but look we have
some good examples of how diplomacy has
worked with the Venezuela enforcement
initiative we announced earlier this
year to address the record number of
Venezuelan Nationals arriving at the
border and look that initiative has
resulted a drastic 90 percent a drop in
the number of Venezuelans Nationals
arriving at the border average daily
encounters are down from 100 about 1 100
a day to 200. so look those those
diplomatic conversations have helped you
know that we've held uh a um a like a
leadership Forum right in La not too
long ago a couple months ago where we
talked to we talked about what's going
on with the Western Hemisphere with with
those leaders and came up with some uh
with a plan on how to deal with that and
so that's because of this president's
leadership and will continue to have
those conversations I don't have
anything to share with you at this time
uh but uh but we'll you know we'll have
more uh in in the upcoming day those
days okay a few things on the same topic
you're asking for 3.2 billion dollars
roughly from Congress to help pay for
all these new or ongoing plans across
the border let's say that money comes in
the Omnibus this week what's the plan
after that to work with Congress to
address this issue like beyond beyond
look we have I mean Ed we have from day
one have asked Congress to help us with
this issue right by putting forward
their Immigration Reform Bill that's on
day one that the president uh had
requested that had asked that that's to
deal with uh modernizing the immigration
this broken immigration system that we
currently have and also to really
protect a DACA recipients and do so much
more and so we have we have reached out
we've done Outreach to Congress we have
asked them and by by acting again
putting forth uh this uh this in this
piece of legislation virtually no change
in Immigration policy with Democrats in
charge
look again we are we've asked for the
3.5 billion we're going to continue to
ask Congress to to assist in helping
with especially Congressional
Republicans uh to help us with what's
going at the at the border if they they
are indeed serious about doing that but
look even with that without their
assistant without many uh Republicans
being involved here Congressional
Republicans we have secured more
resources for the Border uh than any
president uh before that who preceded
him who preceded this current president
he has most agents ever as I said the 23
000 agents and let's not forget he's
taking historic action to seize record
levels of fentanyl from entering our
country and taking thousands of
Smugglers off the streets and that's
without uh Congressional many
congressional Republicans assisting here
so the president has made this a
priority now as were as title 42 is
going to be lifted on Wednesday because
due to a court order we've put forth a
3.5 billion funding requests from
Congress if they are serious about this
if Congressional Republicans are serious
about this they would take the take this
up instead of doing political stunts
and it is big news Across the Western
Hemisphere because migrants aren't just
coming from the northern triangle
anymore they're coming from Chile from
Peru from Ecuador of the president is
here today Venezuela Colombia of course
what is the White House's message to
somebody who may see this somewhere in
the Western Hemisphere and think after
Wednesday it's going to be easier to get
into the United States so look first I
want to say the president of Ecuador has
been a very good partner to us on this
very issue so want to make that very
very clear but again I I stated this to
to Steve and I'll say this again the
fact that the removal of title 42 is
happening in just a day or two doesn't
mean that the border is open it just
doesn't mean that when title 42 goes
away we will go back to title eight
which allows for a process to make sure
that people can have their own Asylum
claims heard and those who do not have a
legal basis to remain will be quickly
removed that doesn't change the process
that we have been moving forward with
since day one of this Administration
look we are are surging surging
assistance to the Border as I've laid
out very clearly as secretary mayorkas
has the past week or so and so we're
going to continue to do that but again
plain English to migrants who might be
thinking about it what should they do
after Wednesday I just laid that really
clear it it would be wrong to think that
the border is open it is not open and I
just want to be very very clear about
that you
um or we're meeting here just minutes
after as darling pointed out they
referred the presumed next speaker of
the house to the Ethics Committee for
defying a congressional subpoena
um I've never really been here before
can the president foresee working with a
house Speaker who defied a subpoena from
his colleague so a couple of things I do
want to go back for a second to your
immigration question I one of the
reasons that I want to be very clear
that to Folks at the border is not open
and and we will remove using title eight
is because by not being very clear on
that we are doing the work of the
Smugglers who are going to put forth
misinformation so we want to be very
clear on that piece look the president
has said from from from the as you know
the president when he was president when
he was vice president when he was a
Senator he has always been willing to
work across the aisle to get things done
on behalf of the American people he said
this right after the midterms were very
clear that we want to continue to work
in a bipartisan way we've gotten more
than 200 bills signed by this president
that were bipartisan bills and let's not
forget the historic pieces of
legislation just on Friday the president
was in Delaware talking about The Pact
act a bipartisan effort that's going to
help millions of veterans across the
country let's not forget not too long
ago just last week we were on the south
lawn celebrate dating a gay marriage and
that was also a bipartisan piece of
legislation more than 5 000 people
Americans were standing outside on the
lawn so we have had those successes
we've had the chips and science act and
we have had others the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation so it can be
done as it relates to McCarthy or any
other any other Republican who to your
question about their role in any of this
I would ask them this is a question for
them to answer about their own actions
and for them to explain
okay when is the president going to sign
the ndaa
he's going to sign that later this week
I'm excited later this week you can't
identify for us I don't have a date for
you can I ask you specifically then the
president's thinking on the fact that
this ndaa obviously includes a
determination of the military
vaccination program so look every ndaa
and I I've said this a couple times uh
in the past 10 days has some Provisions
we support and some we do not clearly
the president was opposed to Rolling
back uh the vaccine mandate but we saw
that republicans in Congress decided
that they'd rather rather fight against
the health and well-being of the troops
and than protecting them so making sure
our troops are prepared and ready for
service is a priority for this President
the vaccination requirement for covid
does just that and while the president
opposes this repeal but with more than
98 of of our active duty troops
vaccinated that means that uh he
overwhelm the bulk of our force is in
compliance with the requirement and
remains protected against covet because
we've seen more than 98 of them are
fully vaccinated so to be very clear
with the president welcomed those who
left the service or refused to get
vaccinated if they now say I want to
serve the United the state's military so
look that is something that the
Department of Defense has to decide on
specific service members what I can tell
you look that again they have a process
on how that runs the Department of
Defense we will let them run that
process what we can say is that you know
the president I said mentioned he's
going to sign the ndaa he was very clear
I was very clear from here about how you
know how he he opposed the fact that
Congressional Republicans removed a
vaccination mandate from from that piece
of legislation let me ask you one more
question just to puncture what we've
been saying about what happened on the
hill today obviously we're getting an
executive summary getting new details
about all of this I know you don't want
to get interfere in any form with what
the Department of Justice is going to
decide but the fundamental motivation
for the president running for office was
as he described that this battle for the
soul of the Nation about 964 people as I
have counted so far I think is the
latest number have been charged for
their role as rioters but we heard from
Jamie Raskin today hours is not a system
of government where foot soldiers go to
jail and masterminds and ring leaders
get a free pass if no quote masterminds
or ring leaders are charged
will the pr how does the president sort
of view the status of this battle for
the soul of the nation so I'm certainly
not going to get ahead of any legal
outcome that may come Evan
I said this just moments ago he huge
that our democracy is still under
that we have to do everything that we
can to protect it he gave two very very
important speeches on our democracy and
where we stand today and so we again he
believes we have to do everything to
protect it and not only do does he
believe that but majority of Americans
who who exercise their right to vote
during the midterms believe the same as
well and so again we have to do
everything that we can to protect it
that's what the president believes he's
going to continue to speak to this and
you know what we saw on January 6 as the
president has said was it was an attack
on our democracy it was the worst attack
on our democracy since Civil War
uh just a question on migration the
president uh tasked the vice president
with studying and working on the root
causes of some of these issues I'm
wondering if there's any update from
this side of the White House on what
she's been doing and what she will
continue to do as we're expecting in
flux
as you know the president uh appreciates
the partnership that he has with the
vice president you're right that has
been her charge to work in a diplomatic
way in finding the root causes of of
migration I don't have anything to lay
out specifically on what that work looks
like but again we appreciate her
partnership and I would probably refer
you to her office on anything specific
on the work that she's doing okay on
another topic the president said when he
was in Nantucket that he will be getting
his physical before the end of the year
I'm wondering if you have any update on
when that will be
um and if those results will be made
public before whatever nothing he might
make about his future political plans so
I'm not going to get ahead of his future
political plans not going to do that
from here as you know I'm covered by the
Hatch Act so really we respect the rule
of law from here so I'm not going to
even touch that but what I can say and
I've said this before the president is
in good health and maintains an active
lifestyle as his doctors have said and
as a as a number of independent experts
also told the New York Times and others
just to highlight that for a second he
will have a physical in the upcoming
months and the results will be released
like they were most recently in the same
way and it will we will be transparent
so is it still the case as he told
reporters in Nantucket that he'll be
getting it before the end of the year is
that has that timeline change I just
don't have a specific timeline all all I
can tell tell you is that in the in the
income incoming months we will he will
have a physical and we will certainly
release those results uh in a
transparent way just like we did last
year that hasn't changed okay I know
you've been asked about this before but
just yesterday representative Cuellar
told Face the Nation that he wants to
see President Biden go to the Border he
said it doesn't have to be for a photo
op but a leader has to show images of
being a
I I just answered the question I just
said we've we've litigated that back and
forth here for the past two weeks or so
the president's Focus right now is to
make sure that we have the resources to
manage what's happening right now okay
does the president um or excuse me does
the White House plan to do anything to
tweak the rules in the inflation
reduction act to accommodate France and
Germany both countries have asked the US
to Grant um Europe the same exemption
exemptions excuse me for nations with
free trade deals for green subsidies
don't have anything here to share then
what I've said probably about a month or
a month or so ago we are talking to our
to our European allies uh about the you
know exceptions that they uh or the the
issues that they may have just don't
have anything to share at this time
France and Germany sort of re-upped
those uh requests within the last two
days I'm just wondering has the White
House responded yet either public or
privately I don't have anything to share
with you on a response but it is a
conversations that we were we have been
having with our uh our European
counterparts
El Paso's Democratic mayor has declared
a state of emergency and he said that he
would only do that when he felt he could
no longer keep his community or the
Asylum Seekers safe he's saying that
that time is now ahead of title 42
expiring
um what is the White House response to
that so look we have from day one
President Biden has taken steps to
reduce disorderly migration while
expanding legal Pathways for orderly
migration we are in constant
communication with the mayor of El Paso
and look I've talked about the
Venezuelan enforcement initiative that's
helped drop the uh the uh the migration
which is as you know an initiative a
drastic Night by a drastic 90 drop and
we're going to continue to do that work
look we're surging we're surging
resources to the Border we're going to
continue to do the work that is needed I
we saw from from the graphs what that
looked like what the res resources were
we're going to ask for the additional
funding the 3.5 billion additional
funding requests from from Congress and
we you know we want to make sure that
we're really truly addressing uh this
challenge again the 23 000 agents that
we're currently seeing at the border
that is because of the work that this
president has done and and these are you
know this is a historic number of agents
that we see at the border at the border
uh again we're going to continue to ask
for additional funding from uh from
Congress to assist us in in dealing with
this challenge at this time the
resources though that you're laid out at
the top
um specifically in El Paso you know
there's there's video that was just
released by one Republican member of
Congress to show that it's really not
making a difference there's one for uh
Patrol facility on Friday uh he says
there are 4 600 migrants in that
facility its capacity is
1040 and
we're still you know teleport 2 is still
in place with their four times their
capacity right now so
is the view that this is working that
that those resources are working that
you guys have said are from the work of
this president to is that sufficient is
it working I mean we're asking for 3.5
billion dollars in additional funding to
help us right with the challenges that
we're seeing so if Congressional
Republicans are serious about this
serious about dealing with what the
challenges that we're currently seeing
uh then they would assist in helping
making sure the men and the women of the
DHS has the resources that they need in
the meantime Department of Homeland
Security is surging resources to the
border and have additional robust
planning efforts underway and so again
we're asking for additional funding we
have surging resources but if they truly
truly want to assist instead of doing
political ploys like they have been for
the past several months they will uh you
know adhere to our funding request that
we've put forward a little bit to Ed's
question though you know this push from
Podium to get Republicans to send more
resources to the Border a lot of them
say that you know they hesitate to throw
more money at a problem with the
homeland security secretary saying that
the border is secure and some of the
people who'd have to vote on that bill
also don't have a lot of details on you
know what's in it and where that money
goes but that all that aside
um
you know
if you're if you're saying that
Republicans aren't doing the work to get
this done and then you have someone like
Joe manchin saying well the president
has the ability to ask for an extension
he should be asking for an extension
because we're at this point where you've
got a deadline and a crisis is that
within the president's authority to do
that
so look we were made we remained under a
court order to lift title 42. that is a
court order that is a quarter order that
is telling us to lift title 42 and we're
going to comply because we follow the
rule of law that is
but it is a court order but that is that
started by you guys it was a quarterator
that has been provided to us and so now
we have to comply and that is we have to
comply by December 21st it is it is a
law that is
what I'm saying is that what I'm saying
that it is a court order that has been
presented to us that we are going to
comply with so you've asked a couple of
questions and I'm going to answer them
if you give me a second so in the
funding request the 3.5 billion I've
already listed them out happy to do them
again you scale up we want to scale up
air and ground transportation
capabilities to move migrants to
processing to less crowded border patrol
sectors and quickly remove them if they
don't have a legal basis to remain set
up an additional CBP holding facilities
and speed up the processing time so
individuals can have their Asylum claims
heard faster hire more than 300
additional agents to join our force of
23 000 agents working to secure the
Border 23 000 that is historic we've not
seen that before and again that is
because of the work that this president
has done giving historic fundings to the
Department of Homeland Security secure
additional Technologies and equipment
like automated processing system law
enforcement radios upgraded surveillance
and inspection Technologies and more
increased support for border cities and
towns like El Paso so the 3.5 billion
dollars there is a plan for it there is
a way forward in getting the resources
that the men and women of the Department
of Homeland Security need to do the work
at the border and but what we have been
hearing from Republicans and seeing from
republicans in Congress is political
ploys they're not assisting they're not
offering any assistance many of them are
not and so we are asking right now if
they are serious about this they are
serious about dealing with the
challenges then they would uh they would
adhere to our funding requests and I
want to be really careful again uh look
you know title 42 is going to be lifted
yes it will but there we are going to
move to title eight the border is not
open and so I want to be very clear
about that because we were doing The
Smuggler's job if we spread
misinformation and uh and so again just
want to be very clear about that and so
I'm going to move on
okay cream with regards to Mansion just
to put a fine point on it because he did
go on to say that I think the
administration is doing that or will do
that with regards to an extension there
are no plans to ask for any sort of an
extension is that what you're saying
what I can tell you is we are required
by a court order to lift title 42 that's
December 21st and we're going to comply
with that order any other additional
questions about any legal actions I
would refer you to Department of Justice
and you've said that the border is not
open you said that a couple times will
the president deliver that message in
person next month in Mexico at the North
American leader Summit again I don't
even have a trip to announce at this
time today all I can tell you is that we
are in plans and conversations so don't
even have anything to confirm to uh to
to speak to a hypothetical okay
President Putin traveled to Belarus
today does the administration have any
concerns that there might be additional
collaboration between the two countries
and concern that you know Belarus may be
providing additional Military Support so
we have long been concerned by belarus's
role in Russia's aggression Belarus has
enabled Russia's war against Ukraine
providing support for Russia and
allowing Belarusian territory to be used
as a staging ground for Russian forces
look we continue to monitor Russia's
Force posture closely that's something
that we have been doing and will
continue to do including a Belarus in
Belarus and remain in close contact with
Ukraine as they've valiantly defend
themselves against Russia aggression so
we'll continue to do that China
acknowledged their first two covid-19
deaths since they changed their their
strip pandemic control policies does the
administration have any concerns that
this change could affect you know the
global supply chain the the the global
economy and it has the U.S been in touch
with China so I don't have anything to
read out on any conversation with China
clearly all of the all of these things
as it relates to the economy we keep a
close eye on but as you know we we're
just not going to comment on China's
policy what we're focused on focusing on
right now is making sure that uh that
Americans across the country get the new
vaccine we know we know the tools that
work uh to protect us from covid and so
we're going to continue uh to speak
directly to the American people and what
those tools are and uh again we uh we
encourage Americans to get that new
vaccine especially ahead of the holidays
I'll come to the back second okay you
mentioned that the president has been in
touch with the mayor of El Paso but has
he talked I said we've we've been in
touch with them with them have you been
in touch with any of the border state
Governors I I don't have any uh recalls
or uh readouts to to provide on any
particular conversations uh but because
we have an uh um uh intergovernmental
Affairs shop and uh clearly they tend to
be in close touch with Mayors and
governors across the country just don't
have anything to provide for you at this
time
you know how important does the
president think it is to get the
Electoral account format passed you know
in these final days of Democrats go
ahead and has a little message would
send to pass that ahead of the second
anniversary of January 6th
so
um I think we've been very clear on that
particular
um
piece of legislation we support it we
continue to believe this is a priority
and has seen and has seen bipartisan
support as you know in both the house
and the Senate and we hope Congress acts
and sends this to the president's desk
okay
thanks Chris oh you want to go first
offline thank you so much questions some
follow-up on the whole bed in China uh
Dr foxy has said that he worries about
the new
um this relaxing of the zero covet
policy kind of resulting a new wave of
infection in China and result in new
variants uh you see United States
considering any uh you know precautions
like you know the travelers from China
had to produce like a negative result uh
test uh in the coming months so it's the
way that we see it is it's important
that countries focus on getting people
vaccinated and making uh testing and
treatment easily accessible and so we
continue to carefully monitor the state
of the pandemic globally so that we can
continue to stay ahead of it that's
always we've always heard us say that we
want to be one foot ahead and so uh
don't have anything more to share on any
specific you know policy as a relates to
China second question so on the same day
when Twitter banned several journalists
account last week and one of the Chinese
human rights activists was also who's
based in Seattle uh her Twitter accounts
were also banned and without any warning
so does the White House worry about this
trained to reporters and activists the
voice is being affected on the internet
you
do that one more time though so her name
is Wang Chi pong she's a Chinese human
rights activist based in Seattle and at
the same day of all you know a lot of
colleagues here including voas Steve
Herman was banned her account was
formerly suspended without warning so
you know like the reporters and human
rights activists their voice is being
affected on the Internet is that a train
that everybody else is worrying about so
social media companies they make their
own independent decisions about content
moderation but our support for free
speech and Free Press is well documented
uh just Twitter as you know is a private
company and they will make their own
decision so on content moderation but
our support again for free press and
Free Speech has been well documented and
so I'll leave it there
occurring could I go oh oh go ahead
thanks I wanted to ask about there's
about a hundred nominees that are under
consideration in the Senate that have
not yet been confirmed this year what's
the plan going into next Congress if you
can't get them all confirmed this
evening so can we nominate them all so
look um clearly um uh our nominee our
nominees are important the renomination
process is clearly important uh but uh I
you know I I know that people have
questions on this I've gotten it a
couple of times but we just don't have
more information to share on what we
will do but right now we do not have any
updates to preview at this time but uh
clearly I I get I get the importance of
the question just don't have anything to
preview of what it's going to look like
in the next Congress on covid you
already launched the program where
people could order tests online last
week through USPS can you provide an
update on how that's going and when's
the plan to close that how
water that's a good question let me
check in with Dr Josh team I know that
it's been very successful I think there
was a pretty high number of folks
requesting for testing I don't want to
get ahead without checking with in with
him on the exact number but it has been
you know has been very successful but I
don't have a time a timeline on how long
it's going to be made available to
Americans
the latest Twitter files show that the
intelligence Community was actively
involved in discrediting the hunter
Biden laptop story does it bother the
president and those at the White House
that a government agency like the FBI
was involved in suppressing a legitimate
news story again I'm just going to refer
you to the FBI I'm not going to comment
from here about that
okay thank you so much on migration on
Titan 42. in June this year the
president was in Los Angeles and with
other leaders they signed a long
Declaration on migration so can you
maybe
um update us on what happened since and
is the administration generally happy
with what other countries in the
hemisphere are doing to tackle this
issue so look we had a very good as you
know very good meeting with those 19 or
20 uh countries from the Western
Hemisphere as you said laid out Ariel a
a declaration look we met with the
president is has had a very good
relationship uh at president of Ecuador
was here they've been a very good
partner on dealing with the migration
issue we've we've talked about the
Venezuela initiative so there has been
some progress on how we're moving
forward with the Western Hemisphere and
the migration issue that we're dealing
with but look you know we're going to
continue to have that diplomacy and that
is something the reason that we have
seen the success we reason that we've
seen that 90 percent drop in Venezuelans
coming uh in into the country is because
of the president's leadership on this
hey green
um Jamie Raskin when he was doing the
criminal referral in the house today he
brought up the Insurrection act and it's
prohibition on people holding any people
being disqualified from future office my
question is uh does the White House
think that that would apply to the
presidency and are there any concerns
about having prosecutors make a decision
that in theory could have can you could
you say that again did a criminal
referral of trump and others and he
brought up the Insurrection act and it
bars people from holding future future
professional office any major office in
the U.S does that apply to the
presidency and are there concerns about
prosecutors as they look at that case
making a decision that could affect one
of the presidency look I I would I would
refer you back to uh back to the
committee that is not something that I'm
going to comment from here about look
we're talking about
um you know we're talking about uh you
know we're trying to be very careful
here a criminal a potential criminal
investigation that's going to go to the
Department of Justice that they're going
to have to make a decision on we are are
just not going to get involved in any
way even with that question that you're
asking me just going to be very very
very very very careful here I don't want
to interfere in any political way and
we're just not going to do that in this
Administration but I would refer you
with that specific question that that
the congressman made the statement that
he made I would refer you to him
on immigration with a quick one on that
um it sounds like you're teasing some
policy announcements for tomorrow would
that be an executive order and are you
looking at expanding the um people able
to apply for Asylum online and fly into
the country just not going to get ahead
of any potential announcement I would
just say you know stay tuned and we'll
likely have a call on it okay Korean
Texas governor added so there's time for
two expires that the Border would be
quote total chaos is that a correct
assessment or what's your response to
that here what I can say and I've
answered this question many many which
ways uh from your colleagues today what
I can say is that Department of Homeland
Security is surging resources at the
border at this time and and we have
additional robust planning efforts
underway and uh you know we we need
Congress to give us the funds we've
requested to do this in a safe orderly
uh in a safe orderly and humane way and
again I'll say this uh this uh one last
time if republicans in Congress are
serious about the borders border
security and actually address addressing
this challenge they would ensure that
the men and women at the Department of
Homeland Security have the resources
that they need to do their jobs and so
that's what we're going to continue to
ask for and request but again we're
doing the work the president has been
doing the work at the border since they
one by first putting forth the
immigration reform legislation and also
securing funding historic funding to
Department of Homeland Security that 23
000 agents that matter that is something
we have not seen under any other
president now we're asking Congressional
Republicans to assist and do the same
foreign